[Musique]
Conseil constitutionnel proclame élu
président de la République quand le
Conseil consuel a été créé il prenait 5
décisions par an donner de la substance
à ses droits constitutionnels
aujourd'hui le Conseil constitutionnel
prend sans décision par an ça donne
toute sa place à l'état de droit le
Conseil constitutionnel mode d'emploi
la Constitution c'est quoi épisode 2
depuis la création de la Cinquième
République en 1958 le Conseil
constitutionnel est le gardien de la
Constitution il est chargé de la faire
respecter en contrôlant la conformité
des élections nationales des référendums
et quand il est saisi il contrôle aussi
la constitutionnalité des lois jusqu'à
avant la 5e République la loi pouvait
tout faire
le Conseil consuel est créé comme il
existe d'ailleurs dans d'autres
démocraties pour vérifier que la loi
votée par le parlementaire et conforme à
des principes plus vastes que la loi qui
s'appelle la Constitution la
Constitution c'est quoi la Constitution
c'est un ensemble de textes juridiques
fondamentaux qui définit les
institutions de l'État organisent leur
relation c'est l'acte fondateur par
lequel une société définit son identité
et son mode de fonctionnement la
Constitution au sens étroit ce sont des
dispositions pour l'essentiel que
j'appellerai institutionnel c'est-à-dire
les relations entre le Parlement le
gouvernement président de la Républica
en 1971 le Conseil constitutionnel va
plus loin beaucoup plus loin le Conseil
a pris une certaine liberté par rapport
au gouvernement après le départ du
général de Gaulle en 71 le Conseil
constitutionnel dit désormais je vais
plus simplement regarder la conformité à
l'aspect institutionnel de la
Constitution je vais vérifier la
conformité de la loi avec les grands
principes du droit c'est-à-dire la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen de 1789 le préambule de la
Constitution 1946 qui établit les grands
droits sociaux la liberté d'associations
la liberté de la presse la propriété
privée le droit du travail et
ultérieurement la Charte de
l'environnement et donc ça c'est la
chair du droit c'est ça qu'on appelle le
bloc de constitutionnalité le conseil au
départ gardien de l'équilibre des
pouvoirs devient donc le garant du
respect de nos droits et libertés et
repoussent ainsi les limites de l'État
de droit la institution s'inscrit dans
ce bloc de constitutionnalité qui
encadrent donc toutes les règles de la
République française je récapitule le
bloc de constitutionnalité c'est la
Constitution de 1958 la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen de 1789
le préambule de la Constitution de 1946
et la Charte de l'environnement de 2004
toutes les lois doivent respecter ses
principes fondamentaux mais pas que ce
bloc de constitutionnalité et le sommet
de ce que l'on appelle la hiérarchie des
normes une pyramide schématique dans
laquelle on retrouve le bloc
conventionnel qui réunit les traités les
conventions internationales et le droit
européen le bloc législatif qui regroupe
les lois ordinaires les lois organiques
et certaines ordonnances les principes
généraux du droit que sont les règles
non écrites de portée générale comme par
exemple l'interdiction de licencier une
salarié enceinte enfin le bloc
réglementaire c'est-à-dire les décrets
les arrêtés de certaines circulaires
comme l'interdiction de faire du bruit
après 22 heures
[Musique]